- There's millions of dollars
inside these envelopes.
- [Narrator] Meet Josh Fox.
- If you wanna change your life,
this is the conversation for you.
You can make $6.3 million.
We love money.
- [Narrator] In the past few years,
Fox has built an empire,
recently with some assistance
from "Shark Tank" investor Kevin O'Leary
by taking advantage of an
obscure pandemic era tax break.
- The Employee Retention Credit Program.
Do you even know what that is?
- This is the modern-day gold rush.
That's what I'm calling it.
- Oh, this is a total gold rush.
- [Narrator] Since 2021, Fox's firm,
Bottom Line Concepts, has worked
with thousands of small
businesses and nonprofits
in an effort to pursue more
than $6 billion in tax breaks,
which could yield Bottom Line
more than $1 billion in fees.
- We're rich.
- [Narrator] But is this gold
rush too good to be true?
- One of the things we've seen
with these pandemic programs
is when you do things
in a hurry, you have
unintended consequences.
(pensive music)
- [Narrator] In March of 2020,
as the coronavirus pandemic
first gripped the country,
President Trump signed
the $2 trillion CARES Act.
- I've never signed
anything with a T on it.
- [Narrator] The largest
economic stimulus package
in US history.
One of the lesser known
parts of that legislation
was the employee retention
tax credit or ERC.
- There was real concern
during the pandemic
that people would get
laid off and lose some
of that attachment to
a particular employer
and it'd be harder to turn
the economy back on again.
The real core point of this credit
was to keep workers
attached to their jobs.
- [Narrator] To qualify for the ERC,
a business or nonprofit
must meet certain criteria.
- To get in, you have to
meet one of two tests,
either your revenue had to
drop by a specific amount.
The other way is you had
to have a government order
that was fully or partially
suspending your business.
- [Narrator] The amount of
a business can qualify for
depends on its number of employees
and which quarters the
business was affected
during the pandemic.
- The number you'll see really frequently
in all the ads is 26,000 per employee.
- See if your company qualifies
for up to $26,000 per employee.
- And I think that's basically
5,000 per employee in 2020,
which was the limit, and then 7,000
for each of the first
three quarters in 2021,
which was the limit for that year.
So you'll see this 26,000
per employee number.
That's the maximum you could qualify for
if you were eligible for
all of those quarters.
- [Narrator] Determining if a
business qualifies for the ERC
and for how much isn't straightforward.
It's also a challenge for the IRS.
- The employee retention credit
is an extremely complicated
filing to process.
- [Narrator] That's where firms
like Bottom Line Concepts come in.
- So I've got the expert with me.
This is Josh Fox.
- [Narrator] Although the
ERC expired in late 2021,
the window to claim the credit
retroactively remains open
until early 2025.
- I want you to get this money.
You'd be crazy not to get this.
- [Narrator] To find eligible businesses,
firms like Bottom Line
are advertising heavily.
- "What's the ERC?" you ask.
- [Narrator] Shark Tank
veteran Kevin O'Leary
is Bottom Line's best known partner.
- What is this?
- This is hundreds of millions
of dollars, literally, Kevin.
- [Narrator] O'Leary told
The Wall Street Journal
why he joined Forces with Bottom Line.
- I said, "Look, I need to
buy a piece of the company.
I need to be a shareholder."
But in this case, it made no sense
'cause this program's going
away in a matter of months.
So I said, "Let's form a new entity.
Let's be partners in it.
We're gonna call it WonderTrust."
- [Narrator] WonderTrust is a website
that connects potential businesses
with Bottom Line.
- I will get behind this.
I'll go all over network television,
all over social and tell
people about this program
'cause I'm a believer in it
and I'll put my own companies through it.
So I'll eat my own cooking.
Mr. Wonderful here, and
there's no debate about this.
- [Narrator] WonderTrust
said it has submitted
about $140 million
in ERC claims for more than 780 employers.
- I'm pounding the table. I'm telling...
Most small businesses know who I am
and I'm telling them this
is mandate number one.
You have months left to look
into this and you should.
- [Narrator] For the businesses
that are unconvinced or
unreceptive to commercials,
Bottom Line has also
created a referral network
of about 50,000 people.
- These are people who are
not on salary at Bottom Line.
They may have another job.
They may be semi-retired,
they may be fully retired
and they're just out there talking
to every employer they can find.
- What else are the
people on this call doing?
There's 600 people today on the call
that you can make $6.3 million.
- [Narrator] One of the tools Bottom Line
has used to recruit potential
affiliates is online video.
- One of the videos
is called "Become a
Millionaire with Bottom Line."
- So 100 clients divided by 24 months,
you have to bring us four clients a month.
- They run through the
math, "Bring me these number
of people and look how
much money you can make."
- So one client a week for
two years, you make 1,300,000.
- We're making millionaires.
This is easy money.
It's a way to get rich.
- Carrie Hagen-Smith
is a Bottom Line Concepts
referral partner.
Hagen-Smith is working
with 24 clients that
she expects will receive
about $1.4 million back from the IRS.
- They have not all gotten
their paperwork in yet,
so it's a very long process,
both on the client side
and on Bottom Line Concept side.
And then we add the third element,
which is the IRS processing.
- [Narrator] Hagen-Smith said her success
has come primarily from
face-to-face interactions.
- My biggest strategy has been
with a partner and we go bold calling.
That's not wimping out and
cold calling on the phone.
That's walking boldfaced
into the business's door
and actually being the local face
that they can rely on for ERC Answers.
- [Narrator] Bottom Line
doesn't require its customers
to shell out cash.
Instead, everyone gets paid
once the IRS issues a check.
- You don't have to buy anything.
You don't have to spend
a lot of money upfront.
You don't have to convince your clients
to write you a check.
You get money at the end
once everyone is happy
and you're helping small
businesses along the way.
That's the pitch.
- Everything we do, we're doing
because you've signed a contract
and you're going to get the
actual check back from the IRS.
That's it.
That alleviates a lot of
those fears that people have
from hearing the scam alerts.
- I actually started digging into it
and looked at people that could
process these applications.
I came to the conclusion,
there's a lot of, well,
for lack of a better word,
schlockers out there.
- [Narrator] Despite
his support for the ERC,
O'Leary acknowledges
that there are some
unscrupulous firms involved
in the ERC space.
- I think anybody that
takes a payment upfront,
I would not use them because
why are they doing that?
- [Narrator] Every year as the
nation heads into tax season,
the IRS releases a list of
the most common tax scams
for taxpayers to be mindful of.
At the top of that list for
2023 was fraudulent ERC claims.
- For the IRS, the ERC
is a giant headache.
On the one hand, what's happened
is because they've gotten
so many applications,
there've been a lot of complaints
that they haven't processed
these refunds quickly enough.
And I've talked to small
businesses who need the money
who really feel they
qualify and they haven't
and they've been waiting.
On the other hand, the IRS is
really worried about fraud.
- Figuring out whether what's legal here
and what's not is is really tricky.
I think we're very much in
the early stages of that.
You know, the IRS has certainly indicated
that it thinks it is seeing,
and the IRS does not name
particular firms in this,
but they've indicated
that they're seeing what they
think are a significant number
of fraudulent or overstated
or ineligible claims.
- [Narrator] In a statement
to The Wall Street Journal,
Bottom Line wrote, "We are
proud of the company's record
of delivering valuable
services to American businesses
with no upfront fees in a
compliant and transparent manner,
including educating small
businesses on the ERC program
and helping them reinvest
in their business
and their workforce
to the benefit of local
communities across the country.
- Look at all these checks I
am actually holding in my hand.